The biggest perpetrators
of any of them were Backpage.com.
We didn't kowtow, we don't count kowtow.
It is a crime that is rightly punishable
by incarceration in prison.
There are more in the world today
than ever before in human history.
In April, 2018, the founders of the online
classifieds website,
Backpage.com, Michael
Lacey and James Larkin,
and five people who worked
for them were indicted,
though one of the employees
has already pleaded guilty.
Lacey and Larkin were accused
of facilitating prostitution
in violation of the Travel Act,
money laundering, and conspiracy.
It's hard to make us feel guilty.
We're not guilty.
We're not guilty, okay?
You can't talk me into it.
The irony was that Backpage had been working with the FBI
and the National Center for
Missing & Exploited Children
to help police investigate
instances of sex trafficking
and the police had come to
rely on its cooperation.
In September, 2021, Federal
judge Susan Brnovich
was forced to declare a mistrial in the case.
Lacey and Larkin's determination to fight all the way to the end
is laying bare what Reason
has been reporting for years.
The government's case against
Backpage is a house of cards.
All along, the big argument
between federal
prosecutors and the defense
has been you can't try
us for sex trafficking
because there are no
sex trafficking charges.
Elizabeth Nolan Brown
is a Senior Editor at Reason Magazine.
She's been covering the case
against Backpage for years.
These specific six defendants
knew that their website was
facilitating prostitution
and conspired to encourage that.
That's what the federal
prosecutors are supposed to prove.
In opening statements, the state took a different strategy.
The federal prosecutor, Reggie Jones, who makes the opening statements,
is just like, "Child sex trafficking!
Child sex trafficking!"
Like just sort of harping on that.
Not trying to tie anything that he's saying
to any of the specific allegations
or ads that are in the indictment
against the defendants.
Just really sort of making this case
based on reputation and rumors.
They told these stories of
these mothers whose daughters
were teens and had ads
posted for them on Backpage.
Allegedly, but I mean,
again, this is not anything
that they have evidence for in this case.
It just was sort of these
very emotional stories.
After the opening statements,
the Backpage defendants'
lawyers were like,
"Hey, we want a mistrial, this is absurd.
This is so prejudicial."
So the judge Susan Brnovich said,
"Okay, you're almost crossing the line,"
to the federal prosecutors,
but I'll let it stand as
long as you just dial it back,
dial it back a little."
But prosecutors called witnesses
who continued to focus
on child sex trafficking
and couldn't attest to
the specific charges
against the defendants.
At one point, California
Special Agent, Brian Fincher,
showed the jury ads from Backpage.
None of the ads actually
said anything like I will give you sex
in exchange for money.
So none of the ads actually
contain the elements
of the crime of prostitution
in the state of California
where they were posted.
And in California, you can
actually be a licensed escort.
You can be a masseuse, you
can give erotic massages.
You can be a stripper, you
can do erotic performances.
There are all sorts of
legal forms of sex work.
Not only was there no
evidence that the defendants
actually knew about these specific ads,
but there was no evidence
that illegal activity
sprung from these ads.
In another instance,
the jury heard from a
doctor named Sharon Cooper,
who works with sex trafficking victims
and often testifies in government cases.
So she got up there and she testified
to a lot of terms that are
very common in sex work ads.
Like "100% independent" is a
thing you would see a lot
in escort ads online.
Which meant just not affiliated
with an escort agency,
an independent sex worker.
And she got up there and said,
no, that actually means that
someone is trying to trick you
into thinking that they're
not a sex trafficking victim,
but they actually are.
And just again and again, she
testified things like that,
sort of making up these terms
so that pretty much
everything that you see,
adult consenting sex
workers posting their ads,
she redefined as a sign of sex trafficking
which involves force,
or fraud, or coercion,
or child sex trafficking.
And eventually towards the end
of her testimony, she said,
when the defense was questioning her,
they asked her about sex work.
And she said, "I don't use that term.
I use the term sexual exploitation."
And sort of went on in that vein,
making clear that she
does not actually think
you can be a consenting sex worker.
So all of her testimony
was very much conflating prostitution
with sex trafficking and child abuse
because she does not see a difference.
And she admitted that.
After Cooper's testimony,
the defense called for a mistrial again.
The judge said she would
review the transcripts
and make a decision in the morning.
So it was very surprising
when she got in there the next morning,
and they all got in there, and she said,
yes, she actually was
going to grant the mistrial
because the government
had crossed the line.
The government had just been harping
on sex trafficking, sex
trafficking, sex trafficking,
and not tying it to the defendants
and that it just was way too prejudicial.
Like it just gave the impression
that a lot of things were
happening on this site
and that these defendants knew about them,
even though the government was
not presenting any evidence,
that that was the case.
Brown uncovered internal
Justice Department
memos from 2012 and 2013
in which prosecutors
admitted that Backpage
not only didn't facilitate sex trafficking
but it worked to help law
enforcement ferret it out.
These memos actually got brought up
during the trial because,
during the opening statements
and during some other statements
that the prosecution made,
they tried to say that
Backpage did nothing to try
and stop underage people
advertising on their site
or being advertised on their site.
That Backpage did nothing to try
and stop illegal prostitution
from being advertised on their site.
And these memos that Reason
published a few years ago
actually show that they did a lot.
They're actually doing all of this stuff
to rid their site of illegal content.
And the prosecutors and
these memos laid out
just the great lengths
that Backpage was going to
in order to try and ferret
out illegal content.
They were obviously letting adult ads,
letting sex worker ads go through,
but they didn't want ads
for children up there.
They didn't want ads that
blatantly advertise prostitution
or anything like that.
They didn't want anything
that was illegal.
And the prosecutor said they're better
than any other site that's out there
doing adult ads or doing classified ads
at getting back to us about subpoenas,
at working with the National Center
for Missing & Exploited Children,
and doing all these things to try
and bring an end to this stuff.
The judge wouldn't allow the memos
to be used as evidence
in front of the jury
because they were given
to the defense by mistake
and were an internal work product.
I'm really glad that
we were able at Reason
to bring these memos to light
because I think they're really important
for people to see that,
while federal prosecutors
and attorneys general were
saying one thing in public,
they were writing another thing privately
that was very, very different.
They'll have to pick new jurors.
The trial might not get back
underway until next year now.
And the defense attorneys
are pushing for a total
dismissal of the charges now.
Brown says that's unlikely
though a hearing to determine
the next step in the case
is scheduled for October 5th, 2021.
Lacey and Larkin are determined
to keep fighting no matter what it takes.
We don't think it's the government's job
to be telling us what to print, okay?
And that's just like, it's not a start.
There's no discussion, you know?
Not gonna happen.